was such anxiety I don't know what  scares me more okay Turk and Mary is  Jillian Michaels ready to settle down  fast talking Fitness mobile shows a much  softer side than we're used to in the  latest teaser for her new docu-series  just Jillian I just you want to know  what the [ __ ] happened and what is the  plan to fix it okay so the tough talk is  still there but fans will also get an  inside look as Jillian juggles a growing  Empire two kids and a longtime love of  her life I don't want you to get married  because you're sick of me nagging you to  get married but I want you to get to a  place where it's like you realize that  it means something to me and like maybe  it would mean the same thing to you find  out how it all plays out when just  Jillian premieres January 19th on E